5 25 on your Wednesday morning so how
does the Nevada Department of
Transportation know who is in those cars
using the HOV lanes and Dot spokesman
Justin Hopkins
the newest thing the sensors that we put
up at 15 locations over the summer uses
infrared technology and a camera takes a
picture of every car and it actually
uses heat signatures he says humans are
helping computers to better understand
the hard data using machine learning and
artificial intelligence to teach the
technology what our occupants to
differentiate between a person and a dog
for instance or between a passenger and
just some equipment or some luggage now
before you freak out about cameras
photographing you in your car and forget
about the cool stuff and I was doing to
better utilize the HOV lanes Hopkins
stresses the pictures taken are not used
for law enforcement
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone you can join the driving
crazy conversation at traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com